talk about getting nominated for best
rap album of the year and best new
artist of the year which i even think is
a bigger deal because that's a much
harder category to crack right as a
rapper
um what was your like
tell me like just your you know
obviously that's a life-changing moment
to get absolutely that when you wake up
in the morning you know i know how those
grammy mornings are when they announce
the nominations it's super [ __ ] early
it's east coast time like what was that
like man we were going to the gun range
ironically enough we were going to the
outdoor gun range
where you know you could have multiple
people in our section we are shooting
down
you know down the lane and
my mama was gonna come all kind of
people it was just a hot day
and um
i'm actually in the car and we get the
call it's like you nominated and we we
had grown accustomed to being
up for consideration so i'm like i'm
like okay nominated like we got the
actual nomination or like or in
consideration for the next stage of
inconsiderate like no you have a grammy
nomination you're like you're going to
be at the grammys
what you mean right you know and then
i'm like oh [ __ ] like that like so it
hit us we got excited
and um
and it kind of that's another time where
our little plants have got derailed
because we already had
what we thought was going to be a
project it wasn't called war and wonders
at the time
we're planning on dropping something
late 2020.
you know like we're gonna hit him in
february we're gonna hit him again you
know and then that happened so it's like
okay well until the grammys happen this
is it's still black habits season you
know
and um
but so getting get nominated for best
rap album
um
i think it speaks a lot to
to
for early for early project for me to my
storytelling ability for it being a
cohesive body of work
and um
for having a very
clear identity among the rap albums that
came out then
um
i think for best new artist
of course it spoke to the body of work
but that spoke to
my my my new presence in this world you
know what i stand for how i show up the
music that i put out the visuals behind
it i think it's just like
people saw saw me as uh somebody that
came in and filled the void not just on
the musical front but on the like
you know i come from you know i grew up
in the 90s right so we had tupac out
there being vocal across different
boundaries it was
you know i was a tupac fan more than i
was a tupac music fan you know what i'm
saying like when tupac was in a movie it
was it was dope right more impactful
movie when tupac spoke about an issue
you wanted to listen
and then when he put out something you
know you wanted to learn it too you know
you know your body is banging baby a
little bit you flaunted time to
you know what i'm saying like you feel
that like because you believe them you
know and i think when we put out music
people believe
like what i say and where i'm coming
from and they want to know more so i
think that worked to our advantage